what's going on there citizens of the
reject nation greg here john how are you
john is excited john apparently we're
never in videos anymore never ever
that's what people say it's just the coy
and sally network now yeah that's all
it's become guys we're going to react
today to the new rockstar she-hulk
episode 2 easter eggs breakdown from
lulu clemens that's what her name is on
twitter go follow her she deserves it
she's amazing she's great at what she
does here leave a like that would be
greatly appreciated and also check out
our she-hulk episode 2 episode reaction
up here on the channel already
welcome back to new rock stars i'm
jessica clements aka the nr she-hulk
here to break down episode 2 for you the
episode gets into jen really planning
her feet as she-hulk glk and h and how
shady their structure is but what i
really love is we get into emil blonsky
and his point of view to the duel of
harlem and the beef between himself and
hulk he's a great good moment good
moment point of view and i love him just
so much the last scene of this episode
gave us our lord and savior that is wong
so let's get into this with some details
that you might have missed titania is
what's referred to as a super influencer
which is hilarious because the term
super influencer super influencer
actually exists for top tier digital
which titania absolutely is she now has
a twitter account with her to facebook
oh cool
her bio says influencer icon global
lifestyle brand where kamala had her
youtube channel maybe titania as a
vlogger content creator influencer
honestly she might just have clothing
hauls and makeup tutorials i mean look
at her those head shots baby's a model
or actress we're one step closer to
getting soups into the marvel cinematic
universe yes let's go
make it happen marvel oh just a show all
on tick-tock about that character make
it happen make it happen we get
different news outlets covering the
mayhem that ensued that day at the
courtroom kpvk and kzyo both appeared in
ant-man and wasp covering ant-man aka
giant man in the fbi room of tvs it's
kind of weird usually in uh la news
stations it's like local based yeah yeah
man's in san francisco you know this is
los angeles so usually they want to be
the same network it's just a really
great coverage we picked it up from
there we have news los angeles now that
could be affiliated with krxj channel 6
news in los angeles we last saw in iron
man 3 they share the similar colors the
headline below reads this which
absolutely could be the case this sort
of messy hollywood celebrity trope
moment additionally
john gregory and rachel brown each play
the news anchors and our actual news
anchors for abc 7's eyewitness news in
los angeles we get our first eyewitness
and reporter in the field if this guy
looks familiar to you he's in black
lightning playing the same character and
objectifying a female superhero my dude
stays typecasted he's the key to tying
them into the dc universe yes we found
it finally
for you genius it wasn't dwayne johnson
it was this guy on the stretch ever he
is they came up with the name she hulk
and thank god it wasn't chick hulk but
like bruce mentioned in episode one you
never have a choice with these names we
make it to the legalese bar and grill
love how green it is legalese is the
conventional way legal documents are
written so sort of a pun either way this
is where all the lawyers hang out and
drink we got the same sort of stylized
sports bar and she-hulk comics also you
know it's a bar of lawyers with all
those justice scales nikki's rights
and in the comics jen has been called
chick hulk and girly hulk before with it
came nothing but danger just don't get
it twisted you know what i'm saying with
this new found she hulk courage she
enters the bar to cheers and applause
completely stepping past the hostess
it's okay she didn't want to see you
guys anyways also the coffee supplies on
the bar hella cool she's wearing a zip
up hoodie because she completely
shredded her original blazer hulking out
in the courtroom the song playing is
celeste stopped this flame truly because
you ain't stopping she-hulk now jen
mentions hoping that the name doesn't
stick and being a derivative of the hulk
which unfortunately is exactly how she
got her name they created she-hulk from
the success of incredible hope the tv
series and with the bionic woman being
so popular it seemed like a good idea
marvel was afraid they didn't have a
fascinating version of hulk so they
decided to publish their own version so
if any movie made something similar
marvel would own the rights kind of like
spider woman it's just easier to
trademark before you know the phrase
they asked for permission before sorry
laters is that what they say later on
jen says it's close enough i'm not no i
did not go to law school and rack up six
figures in student loans to become a
vigilante that is for billionaires and
narcissists and adult orphans for some
reason probably referring to people like
steve rogers thor most definitely tony
stark i'd argue natasha as well but i
just wouldn't necessarily call her a
narcissist you know when nicki suggests
being an adventurer jen says this play
me another clip
do the avengers offer healthcare
maternity leave a pension
are they even paid this got me thinking
yeah what are the benefits now in the
comics they got a lot according to the
avengers u.n charter and avengers annual
they got free health care they had
stipends a retirement fund access to
avenger vehicles weapons and a lot more
but in the mcu it's looking kind of
bleak so remember back in the falcon and
winter soldier when they were trying to
get a bank loan sam's got government
contract earnings so that could make a
lot also since he's a hero people are
inclined to help you you know the old
supe civilian benefits they have free
housing on a vendor's campus access and
security clearance of the avengers
facilities but most of what we know
about their actual benefits is still
sort of up in the air also people like
t'challa thor vision iron man don't
really need the benefits they had
endless money or were just a robot so
they probably overlooked people like
natasha clinton wanda who needed it well
actually it's got me thinking now that
maybe by the end of this series or
whenever she-hulk does cross over into
an avengers movie or even helps out with
young avengers or something like that it
could actually start implementing some
of these benefits and such that you're
speaking of i didn't realize there was
giant ass like legal texts for
everything that i had for the avengers
and that would be a really cool way to
like tie that in especially since it was
really established with falcon and
winter soldier when he's trying to get a
loan dude that's what the secret world
be about it would be the war for them to
start a human warfare to get there yet
they'll all be in the courtroom they'll
get finally unionized and benefits and
all that stuff her d.a boss goes to talk
to her and he's pretty uncomfortable
around she-hulk and asks her to change
to jennifer walters because it's a
serious conversation except her identity
progression should be noted because it's
reinforcing that she-hulk can physically
be too much or dominating or just make
people uncomfy and that's all [ __ ]
when jen changes from she-hulk to
jennifer walter she's intoxicated and
mentions it's because of the change of
her metabolism that is insane and
dangerous she literally can drink 30
bottles and get tipsy as she-hulk but if
she turns into jen she'd be in the
hospital insane and also important to
note our baby girl just got fired for
being a liability in the 2004 comic run
it was the same exact thing she and the
avengers saved everyone on earth which
they concluded to be why the jury had a
speedy verdict if i had a dollar for
every time hulks were seen as a
liability i'd be rich either way it
seems like a very thin line easily
crossed for any superhero lawyer the
show's title introduced a little over
five minutes into the show like other
law shows better call saul allen mcbeal
lawn order sorta does the same thing
though it really opens with in the
criminal justice system sexually based
offenses are considered spatially
heinous in new york city the dedicated
detectives
oh my god you will remember this these
are their stores also below where it
says attorney at law it changes to
attorney for hire bruce refers to jen
that's fuzz ball a lot and in an
interview with cnet with tatiana maslany
mentions mark ruffalo ad-libbed and
called her fuzzball because of her hair
during a take and it's stuck ever since
i think it's just really cute someone
that's the best kind of running fuzz
ball quick hurry anyway
[Music]
we get a shot of jen's apartment with
nikki we see the take out food truly two
mini lamps you have four big windows
what do you need five lamps for and wine
bottles it's hard looking for a job and
i get it let's not forget the velvet
devil merlot bottles sitting on the
table the fish stone baby represent they
also put this devil wine in there to
torment boss i ain't buying it it ain't
the pistol
look at moss's face there that's good
he's
somebody told him to take the picture
right after saying something very
uncomfortable
well looking for new jobs jen's on a
site titled 10 offbeat jobs for a fresh
start by kyle wentz a lot of stuff to
look at here you can choose a sub-genre
fun movies find ant-man probably where's
waldo style game cars norse mythology
whoa there's so much insanity which the
article is currently under and world the
qr code leads you to the same one from
episode one to the marvel website the
actual recommended job on the site is to
be a swiss village mascot that town
right there is called burn in
switzerland the coat of arms of burn is
also a flag with a bear on it their
mascot is a bear so hence why you'd be
their bear mascot also the city does
resemble the city of moon night
certainly if you remember there's some
german signage it also fancies an alpine
village also from this shot of the
actual arts district of the small town
compared to the shot and moon knight
they covered the hungarian stores with
german names so this could be a little
village and burn just a possibility but
mta i think you're right also remember
burn 2000 the science conference where
tony hooked up with maya was also there
as an advertisement i'm just going to
point out my little easter egg that i
noticed is the change in audio is a
demonstration that this was definitely
an insert that you had to do after
recording this originally insanity which
the article is currently under and world
the qr code leads you to the same one
from episode one to the marvel website
perhaps the qr code wasn't available
then so in the process of filming and
editing you had to scan the qr code to
get this access i.e i could tell what a
insert pickup sounds like dude movie
magic destroyed
[Laughter]
as an advertisement don't miss out on
these cool iron man threes
it has tony's heart symbol above it also
this indicates there was an iron man one
and two sneaker if you're thinking dang
i gotta get on those quick adidas did a
collab with marvel and made stark shoes
so i'm sure you can still get them for
related
how is this not about wolverine i repeat
this is absolutely about wolverine who
else would it be this literally happened
in the first x-men movie why there's a
giant statue of a man sticking out of
the ocean
finally
finally
acknowledging that there's so many
easter eggs in this one article i know i
know when i was putting out the video on
twitter yesterday i saw that whole thing
about man fights and metal claws and
barbra i wish i didn't know that so i
could have reacted to that moment in
here in real time that is pretty crazy
to see that they have they're
establishing that wolverine already
exists within the mcu but getting the
tie-in of mutants within miss marvel
like okay so how exactly is this
introduction of mutants gonna work is
this just a fun little easter egg it
seems like they are planting so many
seeds to finally bring us the mutants
and hopefully d23 gives us an answer and
of course why there's a giant statue of
a man sticking out of the ocean yeah
which is just this tiny one sideline
article which should be like a whole
worldwide headline vote to start you
know in the world of the mcu these news
stories are nothing yeah that big head's
not going anywhere after a blip
experience these stories are minimal so
now it's a little after eternals they're
aware of what happened so the timeline
for this show is ever changing head
writer jessica gao said it was a little
after shang chi but marvel's page on
disney plus puts it right after moon
night i think we'll get more evidence as
the show continues to where it really
lands by the way these writers are truly
just the best i love this keep teasing
us go ahead we get a glimpse of jen's
phone the wallpaper is captain america's
ass yes no date though you know for
timeline reasons we're first introduced
to jen's dad morris walters played by
mark lynn baker who's been on a ton of
law and order in alabama and jen's mom
elaine walters played by tess mallis
kincaid who played a judge on bluff city
launch
every actor has probably been on a law
show at least once in their life we meet
uncle tucker played by rightfully
who was also the acting coach on one
division black widow and guardians of
the galaxy what
chad nicholas cerrillo and up melanie
played by candace rose aka chrissy's mom
and stranger things and aunt rebecca
played by elizabeth becca and unless
there's two aunt rebecca's in that world
that could be bruce's mom rebecca banner
which is weird oh [ __ ]
she's allowed to be quiet everyone's
allowed to be quiet i guess but like
that's bruce's mom jen's mom mentions a
nice young man she wants her to meet and
he wants to be a superhero one day and a
super young jessica gao confirmed on
twitter it's her assistant you song lou
but on the closed captions it says yusuf
so it could be yusuf abbas yusuf
appeared in civil war marvel snapshots
number one as the helper who loved
superheroes like the avengers and later
developed some mutant powers i would
have never thought that this family
dinner would have sold easter egg
the article the family dinner this show
is gonna train
yeah is going to train your eye to look
at like the least flashy scenes for all
the juiciest details i feel like what i
love about this is like the banner
family seems so close-knit and
understanding while dysfunctional it
seems like they love each other at the
end of the day yeah we've seen no
support from the banner family regarding
bruce through any of them
no way of presence yeah and it seems
like he still goes to these dinners so
i'm like yeah what is their relationship
that's the next hulk movie to answer
walter's question brought up at the
dinner table that hawkeye guy what
happens to those arrows of his i mean
does he go around and collect them when
he's done hawkeye at times will go back
and retrieve his arrows more so if he
runs out like in hawkeye the series and
in the first avengers he ran out of
arrows he retrieved one from the shatari
he just killed and used his last
arrowhead to make it into a grappling
hook so it's not beyond him to go
recover lost arrows but as for the trick
arrows that have already been used the
arrow shafts that are left behind i yeah
could be dangerous i guess if you
tripped and fell onto it but that's the
dodc's job to clean it up when jen's dad
says you didn't even destroy a city in
reference to hulk's notorious hulking
out and destroying everything i could
yeah break down every time hope
destroyed a city or something but i'll
just do a quick squirrel right here
[Music]
oh my goodness good golly
the lawyer bar is playing ally mcveal
look at it you're a treasure
and with the same amount of little
respect he's so shady this look that he
gives a bartender
again i just want to say if holden is
orchestrating all of this i said it
first now i'm not saying he's anything
wild but let's keep in mind some folks
could be scrolls there's also a little
statue behind jen this isn't quite the
lady justice statue she's holding a
candle it looks like a lot of statues
like this will probably be seen
throughout the show like this one at glk
h and we've arrived at glk and h it's
massive and jen's looking damn confident
that is until she doesn't know how to
open this door she hope would just rip
that off the handles holden mentions how
eccentric superhumans are appearing more
and more in marvel comics superhuman was
applied to those way beyond normal human
physical conditions altogether they're
super humans which we've got into in
she-hulk enhanced individuals the dodc
refers to them as this and miss marvel
in humans which we've seen in black bolt
and multiverse and madness a38 and
mutants brandon and i do a great big q
on this and how classifications could
work in the mcu so go ahead and just
click back on over to that okay
yes ma'am jen showing up to work and at
court as she hulk the complete opposite
of what he wanted in the comics in the
comics he wanted her to only work as
jennifer a sharp returning with a keen
focused mind he's just trying to use her
he's hella sketchy wow
these woke women writers changing
the source material around taking a
perfectly respectable older white male
character and making him a jerk by
putting her in a situation where she
felt degraded i cannot stand this no no
not in my mind
this guy's the new hayward man no
respect that's funny because you they
did change the source material stuff but
either way of controlling the choice of
what she does with her body and her
appearance yeah is is still like
unnerving problematic
yeah negatively affecting and so either
way if he's like no i want you to stay
in your human form because we don't want
you to be in your shiho form or the
opposite i'm like oh both sounds awful
just because it's a command of how he
wants her to appear no yeah it's like
that's a great narrative fulcrum because
depending on which one you choose you
just get a different adventure of which
piece of subtext you're gonna explore
yeah it's pretty neat that you can do
that take a look at all those comics in
the 2004 she-hulk run stu cicero worked
in the basement of glk and h monitoring
all the marvel comic books that people
use for research this could be our stew
and this is where you refer back to for
research it's like a library funny
actually in some ways that could tie
into even
logan perhaps because remember when x-23
wanted to go i forget what it's called
what are the paradise places that you
saw from the x-men comic yeah yeah like
the promised land or whatever you were
calling it yeah yeah and how that was
actually some type of it wasn't
real necessarily but it was playing on
something real yeah and so there was
some foundational truth to it and then
you know what you said jessie okay
i love pug not only is he super
supportive and loves jen in the comics
he's clearly very funny and just kind of
gross here poga has a wild history
paying for school by being a bouncer he
was saved by spider-man and he's just an
awesome bestie he was also adrian chase
oh
people were excited that you pointed
that out in the comments
no the second time i watched him and saw
in the theater i was like turning her
i'm like
it didn't hit me in the moment i was
like that's who it is i wish i could
have recorded your reaction yeah if you
look closer in the basket we have a
plaque for jennifer walter's name the
same cup we saw in episode one the cu
later litigator and office supplies oh
and sorry i almost forgot about the poop
map god i love him so much we find out
jen's first case is the parole of emil
blonsky aka abomination quickly let's go
down memory lane with abomination emil
blonsky was a formal special ops met up
with thunderbolt ross who injected him
with the super soldier serum he tries to
take on hulk so seriously
he then tried to kill hulk in the duel
of harlem and lost he's been mentioned
since almost being on the avengers and
we've seen wong releasing him out of
prison just to kick his ass he also
specifically wants to retain jen as his
attorney that's important to know and
also very suspicious we finally get to
the dodc's super max prison the cube
it's kind of like the raft which we saw
in civil war but this i suspect is in
cali the death valley-ish area seeing as
in the comics this version was in nevada
this is also where the clandestines are
sent to in miss marvel episode 4. at the
entrance it says department damage
control super max prison we see their
dodc sigil this is all legit the entry
guard foley is played by matt scholler
but on his hat the symbol doesn't match
the dodc sigil his hat reads at the
bottom fbp ca fbp stands for federal
bureau of prisons so this one's the
california division the top says
superhuman federal penitentiary with the
symbol looking like the us department
justice logo i think it's suspicious
that the guard's uniform doesn't even
slightly resemble the dod sees could the
supermax prison outsource their guards
right now i think the big cheese
overseeing this is val rather than the
dsdcc she's like the point of contact if
you will we get a little call back here
the signs of the lambs you're gonna see
yeah
when hannibal discloses i love that guy
with some fava beans and a nice chianti
we see emil blonsky played by tim roth
and yes it's the same cell we see in
shanghai truly i go crazy in something
like that and i'm glad wong was sneaking
him out in the trailer when emil blonsky
turns into abomination he hits his head
on the ceiling triggering a red alarm
and wave of red lights the same alarm
sets off when jen steps over the yellow
line it's probably like a sensory alarm
imagine the game operation if you will
but also this is nice
we also see a painting of the sun
setting over an ocean and maybe he
painted it but the calming ocean
presence and sun's getting real low is
truly smarthulk101 he's in mexico doing
yoga by the beach settling with his
inner hulk him and a meal aren't so
different and it's mentioned later that
hulk and him exchange letters briefly so
maybe hulk gave him some advice that's
exactly what i was thinking that's
exactly what i was thinking dude and i
was hoping you wouldn't point it out so
i can contribute to this video
it's okay say it first
say it first with a well actually and
you'll have the whole thing in the bag
that's really that's the deal with that
whole thing i'm like oh [ __ ] she already
got it
we are rendered
obsolete
no need for us to be here whatsoever now
you got to do is start making the jokes
before we make the jokes then we won't
have anything to go off i do like the
concept though that oh they have made up
under false pretenses via emil blonsky's
side because you're like there's got to
be something else up a meal especially
for the fact that he specifically wants
jennifer walters you know totally
totally cause yeah it's like there's
still some disdain you can tell from
emil blonsky's speech when he's
lamenting how you know hulk is praised
as a hero when he was the target yeah
it's like even if it's not like an evil
or malevolent twist there's got to be
some other angle he's playing he wants
him to suffer in some way abomination
chooses not to change and i'm not trying
to be a wild person and connect this to
everything but i mean come on if this
entire game is a game of chess val
probably persuaded emile to reconcile
with the idea of bruce banner ushered
him to hire his cousin to represent him
bonus she's a good lawyer she'll
probably win but along the way will turn
back into abomination when easily
angered by jenner bruce because when he
even mentions bruce there look at his
eyes with pure resentment then gets
picked up by the hands of val then watch
val be his parole officer nicely done
nicely thunderbolt
program and wants to run away with them
on their purchase property for him i
support this polygamy also i think we
see them in the she-hulk trailer you see
jen near a meal cell and behind whoa oh
my white tops and i think crown so those
are not the thumbnails this is seven
partners i'm also like girls you saw
abomination you saw what he did to
harlem why are you over him like oh yeah
whatever it's a commentary on people's
obsession with serial killers that's
right
the mystique draws you in you can't
resist edgar ramirez ted bundy they
always had these crazy six fans just
showing up in the courtrooms man yeah
man that's bigger than rock stars what
it is man crush me a meal speaking of
which they mentioned the duel of harlem
when abomination went wild toe-to-toe
with hulk and the incredible hulk but
what i really love here is emil's
sadness and retelling his point of view
of everything and truly how the us
government let him down and hulk was the
threat which refer back to my earlier
scroll of all the things hulk has
destroyed in the mcu to see how much of
a threat he kind of is but truly hope
didn't really suffer the same as
abomination hulk is kind of a hero now
an abomination is a prisoner it's worth
pondering once we're out of the prison
in baggy jen's apartment she calls bruce
to give him the 401. smart hulk is on
the sikarian class a superior craft why
is it to see his son is it the further
study of the city i think he's been back
after thor ragnarok and we just haven't
seen it because how else would we have
brought back the sakaar gems what we saw
on the first right right exactly
couriership is oh my god it's insane
okay so on it we see the mighty honk
behind him from episode one some binders
and folders on the shelf the big binder
used to follow hulk's evolution why
would he need that a lot of the same
tech from the basement lab in mexico
also hulk get your damn feet off the
desk you're a hoax not an animal i also
like the nod at hulk saying he's
completely different person now that
fight was so many years ago i'm a
completely different person now yeah
yeah ain't edward norton fighting a meal
my dude
ah adr change again well i thought
you're going to get crap for not uh
mentioning that pardon me
that was the biggest red flag on the
whole cutoff where is the mention of the
meta joke even though you obviously
didn't miss it
it's okay saved it you saved it saved it
jess when we see the news it's kdaj los
angeles news 10 who are the same people
outside jen's apartment in the trailer
footage has been released of abomination
fighting wong and shang chi at the
golden daggers club maybe that night in
particular was popular to record the
fights or because of the aftermath
someone released said footage but this
might have also been wong in
abomination's first time fighting in the
ring or in public if this just now got
out well there's a bit of a confusion to
it because at the end of shang qi in the
post-credits scene which is clearly
after the events of shanghai they have
bruce banner there and he's got his
inhibitory inhibitor not a defibrillator
so much rage so he's got that around his
wrist and you know he's just how he
looks at the beginning of the she-hulk
show but now it seems like he's back to
embodying smart hulk he's on his way to
sakaar
so i don't know what the timeline is of
that post-credits scene of how much
further after it took place of chongqi
but that's where some of the confusion
comes into me via timeline well yeah and
i feel like with these shows too what
we're probably going to run into more
and more is shows that start at one
point between two things on the timeline
but yeah go past and so like when she
showed the disney you know order of
things i'm like with the shows that's
gonna get way hard to maintain which is
really difficult with a show that's
really about has a lot to do with
timeline continuity absolutely movie
movie series the whole franchise this
time we close she-hulk with her theme
song but we've got a few courtroom
illustrations we get nikki and her
drinking we get the glk and h superhuman
law division with her nikki pug holden
and who we know as mallory book played
by renee ellis goldsberry who was in
hamilton mountains
in the comics started to hate each other
mallory just kind of sucked she was mean
and super disrespectful to she-hulk all
the time and she was the best attorney
until she hulk showed up she hold cold
in a fridge for her mom while she
vacuums and her dad pointing at a broken
light insinuating to fix it the poop
here diagram given to her by pug with
nicki and she-hulk the mid-credit scene
is jen doing every bit of heavy lifting
work for her dad since chad is
absolutely incapable of helping and
that's everything that i spotted in the
second episode of she-hulk fantastic
work
underscore do it guys rock stars
subscribe to new rockstars for more
breakdowns of everything you love thanks
for watching free blonsky free blonsky
amazing work again jess that was
brilliant brilliant stuff go follow her
on social media you're killing it you're
absolutely killing it and the love for
you is well deserved and happy that
everyone's been so obnoxiously receptive
towards what you've been doing anyway
guys yeah do everything she said to do
and last but not least let's do a pic
michael b
michael
i forgot to mention they've been
covering she-hulk this whole time dude i
haven't seen any of your reactions yet
gotta stay away from the competition out
there yeah i can't afford to be
influenced by your thoughts and jokes
and then i'm gonna start copying how you
are on camera and i don't wanna do that
man i gotta remember to be myself at all
times take inspiration from your heroes
like you
but don't try to copy them so
michael just wanna say keep up the good
work
and um
sorry that i don't watch your videos
anymore it's okay i will study and copy
them myself yeah it's good that we don't
share the same real region
yeah
it doesn't count
it's wash
so just uh keep killing it all the movie
reactions keep not sleeping yeah i know
what the not sleeping reactor face looks
like you definitely got one of those
stick those eyes even further into your
face my friend so keep at it buddy go
follow him omnimedia catch you guys soon
[Music]